[Música]
seguimos en la misma línea para hablar
de salud nuestro tema precisamente es la
viruela del mono y para ello está con
nosotros más romeros a la vendía para
usted más buenos dias angela
efectivamente quería empezar pues
recordando este caso en argentina que
estaba mencionando justo y que no es una
enfermedad ni tan grave ni tan
contagiosa a pesar de pues por el hecho
de que es poco usual está generando esta
alarma y este miedo vamos a hablar de
cómo nos podemos proteger de esta
enfermedad y de este brote con carlos
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia muy
buenos días del doctor pérez y gracias
por acompañarnos un lunes más se sabe
que la vacuna de la viruela humana que
se usó para erradicar esta enfermedad
también protege contra la viruela del
mono qué disponibilidad hay de estas
vacunas y sería fácil realmente volver a
tenerlas
recordemos que marc estas vacunas pues
son vacunas primera definitivo son
vacunas además de eso que se
construyeron masivamente hace unos 40 o
50 años durante la erradicación de la
viruela pero desde hace varios años más
de 30 35 años no se está vacunando para
viruela entonces estas vacunas si están
disponibles pero son poco accesibles
porque es la vacunación dejó de hacerse
hace muchos años y la población que
tiene 40 50 años no esta vacuna entonces
es una vacuna que si se podría fabricar
pero digamos que en este momento estamos
en la evaluación de la efectividad o
cómo se comporta el brote el doctor
pérez es buenos días le salud ángela
gómez
quisiera preguntarle doctor el qué puede
suceder si puede suceder que ocurra como
con las vacunas contra el 19 y la vacuna
contra la viruela que sea accesible en
los países ricos pero no llegue a los
países en vías de desarrollo o por
ejemplo a áfrica donde precisamente la
enfermedad es endémica
angela yo creo que es de lo que debemos
haber aprendido la pandemia es que las
vacunas deben estar donde se necesite
para controlar el brote y una de las
cuestiones importantes de esta
vacunación es que la vacunación
efectivamente corta la cadena de
transmisión distinto lo que pasa en
código es decir que si uno logra
impactar donde está presentando el brote
corta para que la transmisibilidad no se
haga otra zona entonces yo creo que una
de las lecciones aprendidas es que las
vacunas deben estar donde se necesiten y
en este momento es en editorial en donde
se están presentando los focos de
infección
precisamente eso es algo que le queremos
preguntar también nos realmente hará
falta vacunar a todo el mundo porque
pues crece la alarma por esta enfermedad
pero recordemos que hay alrededor de un
centenar de casos como sería en este
caso la estrategia de inmunización
esta es la viruela nos enseñó todo lo
que hablamos de cuarentenas aislamiento
confinamiento
todos estos conceptos a partieron de
esta enfermedad entonces realmente la
estrategia es a través de un anillo que
se haga sobre sitios donde se han picado
los brotes en donde se vacunan a las
personas se hace un bloqueo como una
forma de un anillo que para no dejar
salir la del virus a otra población la
estrategia vacunación en los sitios
donde se está presentando una infección
para controlar la transmisión es la
estrategia que se habría que implementar
en caso de que se desarrollen más casos
en otros países y doctor muchos casos se
han detectado en hombres que comparten
sexualidad con otros hombres y ha
crecido así el miedo de que se
estigmatiza la comunidad del eje vete y
con más como se desmiente que la
enfermedad esté relacionada precisamente
con esta población
no es una enfermedad transmisión sexual
eso está claro es una enfermedad que se
da por un contacto físico con las
vesículas y un contacto respiratorio muy
estrecho a través de gotas gruesas
probablemente los orígenes que se han
planteado hipótesis que haya sido en
dentro de esta colectividad pero nada
tiene que ver ni con la orientación
sexual ni con una enfermedad de adicción
sexual por eso tenemos que centrarnos en
la ciencia la ciencia dices que las
personas pueden ser infectantes en
cualquier edad de cualquier sexo de
cualquier género y que estas personas
deben estar aisladas y que ojalá su
entorno pueda ser controlado
monitorizado y vacunado para que no se
expanda la enfermedad
doctor precisamente basándonos como
decía y como invitado a usted en la
ciencia en febrero una publicación
científica de hecho advertía de que los
casos de mira del mono estaban creciendo
década a década y de que tenía la
potencialidad de convertirse en un virus
de relevancia global citando
textualmente que pasó para que esta
advertencia pues se quedara olvidada o
no se tuviera en cuenta
no se ha tenido en cuenta por eso el
conocimiento que hoy tenemos de la
enfermedad es mucho mejor de lo que si
no hubiéramos si no se han hecho estas
alarmas esta es una enfermedad
relativamente reciente desde los años 70
se escriben los humanos y los brotes
epidémicos se han controlado en áfrica
bastante bien por eso no se ha expandido
globalmente los viajes trasatlánticos la
globalización la migración humana es lo
que son responsables de que estas
enfermedades están en ciertas regiones
ya pasó en china pasa en áfrica pasa en
las regiones se expandan globalmente
conocemos aún más de la enfermedad
tenemos que tener disponible estas
vacunas y hacer una estrategia de
control en los sitios donde se están
apareciendo los brotes pero sin temores
que esto sea una nueva pandemia siendo
muy sensatos de que no es una enfermedad
que tenga las mismas características del
joven 19 es completamente diferente y
que si hacemos las acciones rápidamente
y controlando de esta infección vamos a
poder neutralizar este virus prontamente
dotaciones gracias a usted por su
asesoría y marc a usted el
agradecimiento por hacer el espacio
posible
vamos ahora con nuestra sección del
invitado del